watch the way CNN covered this the way
they're joking about this and again just
contrast that to imagine if Donald Trump
Jr was a crackhead and they found crack
or Coke or whatever at the White House
when Trump was President take a look at
this they're learning that it is indeed
cocaine now again this is part of an
ongoing investigation we're trying to
get more from the Secret Service as
again how this got into the White House
and who brought it in all of those
questions still lingering but at the
very least those lab tests are now in
the field test said cocaine now these
more conclusive lab tests yeah I would
like to know Blow by blow who was
responsible for this too soon there is
no Tuesday no one was injured as far as
We Know
and
it's an illicit drug at the White House
why can't you actually have a bit of fun
with it I don't believe in fun no he
doesn't thank you so much
that is a CNN daytime anchor basically
telling people to do cocaine if you want
to have a little bit of fun I mean the
carrying water here Barn's like oh my
God yeah it's absolutely to another
level and it's because they all know I
mean that the for those that don't know
the only people who don't get searched
in going into the White House or family
so the that's why they know that this
wasn't searched uh Secret Service won't
fall on their sword for this and so the
net effect of it is that everybody knows
it's hunters and of course they know
Hunter's habits and Hunter's history and
there's you know documentary Visual
Evidence effectively by what we saw
there so everybody knows and the
question is do they all have to hide do
they all have to pretend and it's really
it like I said they keep showing the
naked Emperor over and over and over
again and rather than hiding in behind
the curtain they're just demanding
everybody look and pretend he's not
naked
Viva one more conspiracy theory for you
it's actually not Hunter Biden's it's
Joe's and they have him do a little bump
so he appears slightly cogent when they
send him out there what do you think uh
the bottom line is it It ultimately
doesn't matter whose it actually is but
that they say they can't determine it
it's laughable on its face and they're
they're treating people like they're
idiots or that they have so much power
they can lie to them and treat them like
idiots and there's nothing you can do
about it
um but uh we all have our strong
suspicions uh just to compare and
contrast everything everything they have
accused Trump and his family of having
done or doing is exactly what Biden and
his family have in fact done and
continue to do from the quid pro quo
extortion of foreign interests to the
actual PP you know the the strange
hooker stuff I haven't looked at
Hunter's laptop in its entirety I'm
scared to
um everything they've accused Trump and
his family of doing is exactly what
Biden and his family have been doing and
I agree with Barnes these two kids you
know Ashley Biden leaving her diary at a
halfway house Hunter Biden leaving
abandoning his computer at a story it's
a cry for help or they have such deep
hatred for their own father they're
trying to take him down but you know
Biden his uh his Entourage won't let it
happen but that's that's a little
Freudian um Freudian analysis there one
one addendum I don't think zelenski was
probably real happy to have his photo
next to that story given his own
particular interesting habits shall we
say well but yeah exactly zelenski's
doing a lot of this too so it really
does make you wonder